we're turning now to the hunter Biden
investigation and an IRS agent's first
TV interview since speaking to lawmakers
as a whistleblower last month this is a
lead investigator exclusively telling
CBS News he felt the president's son
received preferential treatment and that
he was blocked from pursuing
investigative leads that could have led
to the president himself Chief
investigative correspondent Jim Axelrod
has his interview once again Jim good
morning Good morning Tony Gary shapley
has been at the IRS for 14 years and
told us that the way the hunter Biden
investigation was conducted was in his
words quote outside the norm
if this was any other person they like
would have already served their sentence
Gary shapley was a lead IRS supervisory
agent in operation Sportsman the
investigation into Hunter Biden shapley
said he uncovered conduct that warranted
more serious charges there were personal
expenses that were taken as business
expenses prostitutes sex club
memberships hotel rooms for purported
drug dealers how much did Hunter Biden
owe in taxes so from 2014 to 2019 it was
2.2 million dollars the back taxes were
paid off and last week the Trump
appointed U.S attorney in Delaware David
Weiss reached an agreement with Hunter
Biden the president's son would admit to
a firearm charge and plead guilty for
his failure to pay taxes if a judge
signs off the deal means no jail time
testimony we have just released details
a lack of U.S attorney Independence and
shapley told lawmakers the U.S attorney
Weiss was blocked from bringing stronger
charges but U.S attorney general Merrick
Garland said last week that Weiss was
not I'm saying he was given complete
authority to make all decisions on his
own and then a letter to house Judiciary
chair Jim Jordan three weeks ago Weiss
himself wrote he had ultimate Authority
I documented exactly what happened and
it doesn't seem to match what the
attorney general or the U.S attorney are
saying today shapley provided lawmakers
this contemporaneous email he wrote
after an October meeting last year
shapley says Weiss told him the opposite
that Weiss is not the deciding person on
whether charges are filed it was just
shocking to me shapley who is still
working for the IRS told us that even
before President Biden took office he
was directed to avoid leads involving
Hunter's father there are certain
investigative steps that we weren't
allowed to take
that could have led us to President
Biden and you wanted to take him
we needed to take them and you weren't
allowed to take them that's correct
now it is important to point out that at
that point in shapley's investigation
Donald Trump was still president and his
attorney General William Barr had rules
in place that may have limited what
shapley could pursue the U.S attorney's
Office in Delaware had no comment Hunter
Biden's attorneys did not respond to us
but he has said before in a statement
that he is taking responsibility for
mistakes he made during a period of
turmoil in his life the question is the
scale of these mistakes and also the no
comment from the Attorney General's
office in Delaware that's what we need
to clear up right so Hunter Biden's Camp
points to David Weiss and say look this
is a trump appointed U.S attorney and
he's saying he had ultimate Authority
and this is what Justice looks like to
him these charges
now he's saying he had full Authority
shapley told us yesterday and this is
critical that on October 7th 2022 David
Weiss looked him and a bunch of others
in the eyes and said hey there's things
I can't do there's limits there's
roadblocks so which is it the only guy
who's not talking David Weiss so far
anyway yeah what does that say to you
Jim that he's not talking well U.S
attorneys of course are going to be very
cautious about any and remember this
hasn't been signed off by a judge yet so
we probably won't hear at least for a
couple of weeks because there's no
upside for the US there'll be some
choppy Waters between now and when that
judge signs off or doesn't exactly yeah
thank you Jim